[Music]
the difference between being behind the
camera and being on camera now that
you're on camera
there are things that that people worry
about right you know like certain
cosmetic things yes that you don't have
to worry about when you're directing no
or back when I was a right around the
Simpsons or saying I live I never had to
worry about what I look like no you have
to kind of worry what kind of things
specifically are you worried about are
you taking care of um it's it's really a
head to toe operation kind of keeping
this thing together and presentable yeah
but it's I'm a sweater I'm a big sweater
let's you sweat a lot I just sweat a lot
I'm a big big sweater I'm interesting
cuz you're not sweating now you seem
like you're very dry well I've got it
under control
I've got it I've got it under control I
was cooling myself I learned I got a
great tip from Eric Stonestreet you guys
were on a modern family I saw him at on
the on the red carpet of the Emmys where
all men share their best beauty tips and
he saw me struggling because it's in the
summer and it's tented and I was really
it gets really hot people sweat you know
people sweat but I people were concerned
for my well-being and I was like it just
it happens it's fine and he was like
dude you gotta check this out and he
opened up his jacket and he had a belt
of ice packs around his entire body oh
look that's the - I'm like that's the
secret cuz that's the secret and he gave
me an ice pack and I put it in my pants
and I was fantastic because I looked
great and I felt excited this desserts
don't treat mind you telling everybody
that he walks around in an iced tuxedo
you know that he's his whole is he's
encased in ice well you know I didn't
really clear it with them that's a great
point that's a great point because yeah
you've done that so you do the ice what
I'll do the ice and I I I'm spoiling the
image that you guys have of me as this
perfect man I'm sorry to be ruining it
uh I have nose nose hairs big thing I
texts from my wife you know and she'll
say to me honey like like even today
she's like look I know you're gonna
shave but make sure you get your nose
hairs make sure you take care of your
sweat she's always giving me tips so my
nose hair management I really get in
there you know like a weed whacker what
do you have basically
I mean I would try I would get it all
cleared out completely I don't know why
people don't do that people shave and
wax everything but I really I mean look
guys this doesn't just happen you know
this is a lot of care and intermittent
dieting and exercise is your question is
yes because you're working with Rob Lowe
that does not help okay we chase him at
Rob Lowe's swear to God I bumped into
him a couple of weeks ago every time I
see the guy he looks do you know you're
about the same age
he looks perfect yeah I always look like
a raisin that's been beaten Ali perfect
and he said to me moisturizers and
creams and I said what are you talking
but he said creams and moisturizers and
he said I keep little I keep it in my
pocket yes and he dips his hands into
his pockets and when no one's looking
yes putting stuff on his face it's a
full-time job to be like that and I and
I you know I got all the things going I
can't if I if I put in the time and I
know you do something to yours and
you're not coming clean with it but
we'll let it go
you